oh guys this is me and my best friend
your mommy's best friend yeah yay you
love me
yeah forever cardi b's three-year-old
daughter crashes her
insta live and it's four straight
minutes of
culture cuteness she's so cute i love
her
the up rapper went live on instagram
monday night and her little girl whom
she shares with rapper offset
wasn't really feeling it at first i'm
for
two you boys hi
i need some snack time
you bored yeah eventually culture came
around and the mommy
daughter duo talked all things potty
training
i feel bad because my daughter she don't
have a sleepy schedule
but at least she's potty trained right
you go to the toilet
and let me tell you something about her
right let's say if
it's 5 a.m or 4 a.m and she's sleeping
she will wake up and she'll be like
mommy i got to go to the toilet
like one thing about her she don't pee
pee or [ __ ] on herself she a good girl
right
they had fun playing and making funny
faces and noises at each other
i'ma bite you because you was being a
bad girl you was crying and you didn't
eat your food today
oh stop it i'm
sorry okay
eww you put snacks on my face
and get ready to feel all the feels
because little culture said her famous
mom
is her bff your mommy's best friend
yeah yeah it just doesn't get cuter than
that
say abios but this isn't the first time
culture has crashed her mom's
insta moment mommy
yes yeah
back in november cardi had to scramble
to shut down her sexy selfie video when
her little one
unexpectedly popped by
[Music]
mommy yes yeah
cardi goes from sexy mama to mommy mode
in a matter of
nanoseconds so impressive mommy
yes yeah
the grammy winner captioned the clip
quote i can't even be
sexy in peace of course cardi and offset
are currently expecting their second
child together and last month cardi took
to her insta story to talk
pregnancy cravings with her fans and for
her
it's all about the meat i don't really
eat burgers that much i used to eat a
lot of burgers when i was younger like
teenager in my early 20s and now i'm
back at it again and oh yeah
barbecue sauce barbecue mead grilled
meat
is a real fat craving baby
cardi also shared these beautiful
maternity photos of her growing family
on
instagram there's some big big things on
the way big bangs
and when it comes to family it seems
like cardi's always known she wants a
big one
in 2019 the new york native told et she
was
ready to give culture some siblings what
does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's
indescribable it's like
like love joy it's a
switch you know what i'm saying it's
like
an automatic smile so it's everything
everything so if one brings you this
much joy
would you double the joy i want to have
more kids
you do yeah